[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Alex Pasha I got a shout out oh we got a
super check and watching music already
man filed out with super chat
he's height that's what's up man trouble
you already here while we were warming
up cooking up here here with the king
let me know if you get a king we do some
night check what's going on what's going
on yo here today yes this is some
earlier - he was like he said topic
first so the rest is sure to have hi
that's my table make sure let me know if
y'all need chat got the hit King I can
hear me good make sure you know migraine
nobody talking Minnesota assume this
loss will be like the last console of
Minnesota will retract but a station
what's a good all right other things
says yes so that means yes you can hear
both of us right let me know the only
one that's waiting for this band to get
up so I can get to this gym all right
perfectly our mom me others saying thank
you brother thank you both so we just
chillin we just waiting for solve and an
addict to pull up within the next 15
minutes it's Jana
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh wow salut Comex man welcome to the
round guys yeah we sorry I we advocacy
the bushes we don't know what's going on
so we gonna give him like another five
minutes or so to hopefully you can join
it process so that's what's going sit
there let's put the shields in it
adequate to bed early City still yeah
XCOM folded at fax right right you just
play that XCOM that's what it was there
was the new joined the drummer
well he's ba he bought the old joint so
he you know height for the new didn't
have that already but he heard that
already well didn't know I know I'm
talking about the old one he didn't have
the old memory he just plays the game he
plays expose yeah yo shadow to stick it
added forgot it said me you'll make sure
yahoo solve okay yeah okay
Belvin Lulu adequately area for
you know we're talking about for another
five or so will be zhamuhe and we'll
start this thing up hi John
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right head we are live welcome to
the iron law podcast and the Lords of
Gammons dotnet episode number 154 game
before today what's going on brother
I see every Jeff like that's what's up
man and it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the roundtable on the
Lord's Day and today we've got PS 5
console availability switch 2.0 rumors
is Xbox Lockhart imminent and the return
of turn-based strategy games to discuss
so we go get right into it
so let's introduce the well we've got
four horsemen right now we're one of our
horse of it is that we don't know with
attic attic is missing all shout this
very Smith man let's put it on for
Smitty Smith finality which at salute
iron Lords and a chat the book of extra
loot what's going on Lance ville Paul
Anthony chipmunk cat daddy fast axe and
the FA's lethal migraine in there
popping balls you already know salut yah
that's what's up but um yeah best we got
we a horseman down hopefully at it could
find his way to the show we have our
gaming Lord mr. low game who lives for
the single-player self experience and
also disaster darkness mister or flaw
profile Illuminati in lower-paid shot of
the iron bank bomb man Lord sovereign
how are we doing sir
I'm doing good fantastic feeling back to
100%
that's our soap so flushed his insides
out baby
Oh Charlotte put up the crest right now
for JD game $10 super chapped super Jack
works support the Lords and hit that
like button
bust my love brother yo what's going on
but so they're feeling better you know
saying it what's been going over to
otherwise man it's chilling mentioning I
go back to work tomorrow so after 19
days of being a couch potato I have to
go back
we didn't break though you yeah well
good work yeah so I definitely did so
yeah so whatever I've been playing so I
played a little bit more Final Fantasy
but I did I got sidetracked cuz I said
you know I can't have looked at my xbox
with my xbox again burn right now this
is not a normal thing so it's gotta be
referred to you I gotta turn the Xbox
one I'll turn it on and AC Odyssey
grabbed me yet again like that's a game
I'm gonna be playing for like a decade
yes acid Creed guy like that's the thing
about it is that never it's too much
I'll never say that the game has too
much content but this game the game
nuts it's absolutely bonkers so what I
decided I said look I reached level 52
right so I'm a sense of that at this
point it becomes a Wonder Woman game no
I'm rocking with Cassandra definitely
yeah much better so it literally is a
Wonder Woman game inside of me allows me
to play it's an amazing game is it
Gustav gasp off-screen not good because
you're so powerful you don't need wanna
play stealthy like you just want to rip
through everything so it it is the go
Assassin's Creed game I will say no no I
think origins is a better game above
that one because and this is the only
reason why I say that
mmm origins gave you just the right mix
this joint is like a buffet it's another
anything it is literally never-ending
like this very stiff is back y'all be
right back responsive chat legend has it
my fellow warlord Cognito is still
searching for a PvP bats or stadia hang
in there brother or wait till they get
to my part I got sober
you two wait right I got you bro yo
shout out the graphic all for the good
to go yo salute the graphic guy yo yo
he'd be always hooking us up man take
care of realm got that new dude you
don't say it's me because that cool
thing was not supposed to be here but
stitch I see you and he said are you
done with the stitch we even start the
show
are you already asking if we don't
attack continue so that's it that's it I
just decided now to finally try to
beeline the story but even that doesn't
matter like you behind the story it's
still like 80 hours with the story in it
so whatever I'll finish it I'll finish
it in 10 years I just stopped playing um
but it is the good thing about it is
like literally I can stop playing for 2
months come back and in 15 minutes I'm
back in the flow yeah to the point when
I was hunting the little red horn dudes
like and this is the thing about it
right there is no end to that they keep
coming so there you get an achievement
for reaching level 50 which makes you
the top mercenary right ok but then once
that happens a new tier of mercenary
opens up as an s-1 level as to level you
know anything about it it's like I have
I have the difficulty slider at medium
which means that all of the content the
lowest below your level it can be is two
levels mm-hmm so you're always
challenged right you ask people at your
level above your level a little bit
below but you're never blowing anybody
out of the water and so the thing is
they they come and attack you at the
most inopportune times like when you're
trying to like infiltrate a fort or
whatever and get all the stuff you need
in a fort or whatever literally two or
three of them will attack you at a time
in addition all but the thing is at this
point I could handle them I'm doing
moves like I'm blowing them out of the
water like and doing these magical moves
it's it's it is literally a one-woman
game without the last no doubt the last
Oh Oh Smitty Smith is back again Toto
crest up to our chat can we get a or
goddamn no sure
or emo graphic art the people want it
kick is lady naeun graphic God's gonna
cook it up you gonna see on guarding
them for real I want to see the actual
emoji for that how that look you say you
gotta say that wardrobe was on that drug
is delicious made it to this 1% switches
in the bushes okay thank you we heard
you Chris so so let me ask you this all
like so basically you went back in you
like you able to pick C Mon thick it's
like I'm not able to when I leave an
open-world game for a while it's been
for me to just jump back here so you're
able to just get right back in remember
what you're doing in these these when it
comes to open-world action games like an
AC Odyssey is kind of like an RPG but of
the whole time I saw the intro and
everything else it is killing you you
know what happened is like I checked I
kept checking my phone it's like 11:30
Azshara I got like I got like 40 hour 40
minutes to an hour left and then I and
then when I just woke up and I looked I
was like my phone's dead because I have
an alarm on it's calm last night oh yes
yeah I after I did the last thing I was
like I looked just like 4:30 I was like
I gotta go to bed
you missed your intro I just gotta ask
you as far as so just bid next when
that's gone that's all you've been
playing so yeah that's all no that's you
getting ready for this this week that
what is a chimera coming out mm-hmm and
gears whole sting is killing you
originally LexA he said Lord had it you
know what had happened was like I said
man I've been here the whole time
yeah yeah we do so that's bits of
otherwise yeah pretty much that's pretty
much me and you know I got to get back
to final fantasy so I'll do that during
the week please get that done because we
talked about I want a couple yeah I did
not watch and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS gamer
ooh the Lord of combat sports king of
the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement Oh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir do
you know exactly I don't know but before
we get started fire that is probably the
most intricate statute I had to put
together and I am not in any rush to
move to a new place to take him apart
and put him together as they come I
absolutely love the journey that the
statute put me on and this week coming
up I got a statue that I was hunting
since my first Incredible Hulk statue to
me this is that the reason use our young
people about the whole thing
yo-yo is calling in as you had
juggernaut dudes it's actually you know
stronger than the hall called Kiki Hawk
and it first of all first of all it
boils down to the writer right that's
right
yeah who's love writing a story
they're gonna show you who won but if
for seven times and a hawk beat him six
I mean my man is up on you
man my man is up on one do cuz I posted
the picture of the juggernaut standing
next to I was just want to see how they
look together these dunes turned it into
a fight like hold it chug and I will be
him and I said you know you're talking
to a comic book historian lately feeble
knowledge talking let me smash you yep
why would you have me do this to you so
my whole logic with the juggernaut is
this anytime I just smack your helmet
off and you defeated they disrespected
him my pulling his pants down and
sticking the cable in his butt and
shocking him to sleep
he needs way more people if they could
pull your pants down this is just did
some high school joint to him pull his
pants down and put electrical cord in
his butt go him in the water
Deadpool to well you know all the x-men
do it everybody is taking a turn at
popping his top I like the juggernaut
yeah but are you talking about my man's
enough disrespect my man was so strong
and when he walked he was cracking the
tectonic plates on the earth you I
really need you to fall back and know
what you addressing the Menace all right
now I respect there's a good on what
you've been playing said oh oh journey
to the savage planet shout out to my men
Phil dumbest Maximus Spencer sir daddies
don't definitely once I saw that game is
he when I saw it on a summer jam screen
mmm
and then I was waiting for that game you
know everybody's laughing no they gave
me some full of crap that's inside game
past well that full of crap is fun to me
bring my son and I are actually playing
this game
and we're in a battle on who can you
level up faster than we play
cooperatively you know it's it's such a
fun game and they have those aiming
moments it felt like like a 3do game
like the full motion video inside and
the acting because they send you to
space right and I know the mission is
for gays II and it for you they need you
to scan stuff in and rise up and your
leveling up but you lost on this planet
and you pass you go find different
material and encounter different aliens
you get different power-ups like the ax
suit you fill your guns and stuff but as
you're going you're uncovering the
secret of this mountain here with this
castle and it's visually pleasing this
is a segment to go though oh you don't
mean that is an original concept because
I feel that go is original ideas oh here
go to sleep you know like you know how
where people do stuff like it's like hey
this is what I Kobe Bryant can never be
to go right I feel you I feel right no
you go Michael Jordan was there first no
Jordan no cool so you had docked up the
template to look at to take this down
[Music]
Mariano find out a super chat it's the
Lord's Day a good day thanks the Lord
for keeping me entertained and informed
while I work
hit the like button everyone solo stays
safe you already know no that's right
Philly Eagle no dr. Jay no magic Jordan
yes panel no I mean no no no no jointer
but okay do me a favor right you look at
dr. J right this his style really look
like Jordan I feel that but I feel I
feel that Kobe is no disrespect but I
just say there's more of a a replication
of his exact out the fadeaway the style
you know I'm saying whatever whatever
whereas dr. J was cut you need to do the
dot you know the duncan and from the
dotted and all that but he wasn't wavy
like Jordan was wavy like you know I'm
saying it's hard to describe but I get
where you going I get me going but who
does have a good point
no it's always somebody in front of us
to show us the way but when you start to
pat in your style
yeah or for somebody else's style yeah
it's very hard to consider you the goat
like I would even consider little wrong
the goal you're getting a lot of gold I
will consider LeBron the goal over his
style is okay he got his own style
you got bunches you know I disagree with
you on this I gotta give you that like
he does he got his old thing yeah he
don't look visually pleasing like play
ball like he looked like a big boy like
a freight train freight rail really and
let it like bottle you talking about you
talking about LeBron I'm I was I was
assuming that super chat was about that
so we gotta send out super chart from
kid smooth sup solve Odyssey is great I
beat main story I'm level a 59 over
eighty six hours in still 30 hours of
expansion story to do I agree with King
origins is the go yeah I told you there
is something around there really seems
more human Egyptian like look you know
check us check this out smooth I'm at
level 52 and I have a hundred and fifty
hours in the game oh my god
that I still haven't beat that game but
that literally might be the best open
ninja game has ever made
that's big from you that's that's one of
the very few games I can give games like
Skyrim a run for its money no angry
Uranus never mean it sir okay yeah no
doubt and of course we have the gaming
ninja himself the shinobi lore kognito
spreading their illness in the realm of
the ILP not telling what you wanna hear
but what you need to hear so for me man
look man finally I know life tick attic
nose finally beat that Final Fantasy 7
remake man fantastic man so much to say
again for those who beat it please shout
out the whole or shout the BG j Bari
attic was there and of course Lords a
gaming dotnet old Lord Marshal aka
Hector we had a spoiler cast yesterday I
advise you guys if you have the game and
you played it please watch that it was
really intense we all got our theories
it's a very controversial ending let's
say that so please check that out man
and of course if you missed on Friday
the best damn destiny podcast you've
never heard my man Lorca any boxes or
the last word was fire we had mr. Aires
also looked at mr. Aires because he
armed he folded us last night cake
he folded his dude is dumb nice and all
and crucible and all that so the new
hustle right now cuz that's these in the
bushes these in the bushes just point it
out there we thrown up the bushes for PC
destiny it's actually PC by being the
bushes right now watches over PC
whatever they fold and call of duty war
zone with all these hackers oh yeah the
folding scheme and trials of Osiris but
all these hamsters
ain't BOTS all its foolishness I mean
you know it's fun you know a 20k I know
I know where this conversation about to
go you better get in you know we have to
make a tough decision
where's my man Forte for take that crust
up cuz you don't want to talk to you but
on we have to make a tough decision man
because it's like obviously PC 60
frames-per-second destiny goodness field
of view did you got Xbox which got the
4k HD but it's only 30 frames and the no
nvme and no SSD so I'm just like Oh
Stadium I have to get to that Stadium so
here's the baby I hate that I would keep
it up up now there it has this weird
film gray it look like tech being washed
out like they colors no but they colors
is water it is the old Chinese flick
right yeah it got that grainy like you
know say like you watch the 1970s joke
Phil will you join bun 60 frames no
field of view no you can't pull that so
basically it's the Xbox version washed
out but with 60 frames so you know and
you knows a little input layer here
there's no such thing a little lag when
you come to a first person shooter bro
yes I listen when Michael's going at you
I'm not now I got to stand up we watch
this right now and I got stand up I
gotta pull my Eve on this for you he
said he went at you directly and told
you there's no such thing as acceptable
input lag a horror code is anemic rest
up with cold finalizing chat I keep
telling y'all PC gamers is full of
cheaters consoles bro it's like I love
this experience and these dudes is out
here warning it you're the people that
go play go back to the Xbox you just cut
it out stop - because with me series of
eggs
I need the Tower of Power it can't come
to be affair yes it'd be fair like I've
heard them both play inch of I've heard
them play in steam and I've heard them
play in stadia and they sounded way more
entertained and stay D than they ever
did it static now it's bringing there's
a couple there's a couple of different
reasons well you know what let's be real
maybe all the competitions are on
Stadium winning but see the thing is but
the thing is like regardless what's
going on there at least having a chance
on stage there's not so much you
fighting Tito for the black
Gogi trials lighthouse member no melt
remember back in the days of there was
the regular court and there was defeat
ease in the hoods over the biddies
because I'm going to the booties without
shacking up
listen I gotta get to the lighthouse man
I'm telling you right now if you try to
get to the lighthouse get old stadia is
loopy over there baby oh oh it's nice so
I was doing that joint you know say
before taste Sinister's in a building
you know seriously we'd get five with
six weeks on oil PC because dudes are
cheating in round one it is it is pretty
bad on PCs like I was playing a couple
and you know I think people cheat on PC
more than people think
Nolan it's just some people are very
discreet about it you don't know it's so
bad they have a stat right now with the
amount of people that go flawless to the
amount of people like people got to saw
people got 99% headshot accuracies
people got KB's in the tent how is the
anti cheat it's saying they do your is
so bad you can't even get when you feel
like what you gonna do I don't have that
problem you know where everything is ya
know we know where is a fair play ground
is it bring yourself back a lot I'm
coming home that's in fact 60 frames I
need three right now stop now we're not
doing that muddy that that slow my last
payment we're not doing stay do with the
free food robbery 99
Shantanu stitch pilot super jet d'eau to
crest up my hat off to all you who
bought the Final Fantasy 7 extended demo
gonna cast arrested podcast later I got
a clock back in no doubt said you're
eight states safe my brother and then of
course we have the grounded gamer with
the finalists of a chat we console
gamers have been seeing it for years you
can't play competitive games on PC
without running into these dudes PC
gamers are cheaters bad it is to this
sob it's so bad the Xbox community is
telling activision to disable cross play
get them out of that jerk because I
heard already that's a little harder to
get them out of there
you don't say so because I guess it's a
little bit more somebody on destiny that
was cheating on PC how to kill death
ratio of a cousin as somebody who tried
to play a counter-strike back in the day
go for God and that and and that's a
community where it's like like there's
so many professional players that like
they go out of the way to try to police
it as much as possible but earlier on
before that that sort of a that eSport
aspect of it really got big yeah bro
don't get people's mindset with that
like it's it's like it's like you're
never going to be good like you're
always gonna be the person that needs
some kind of app to be good like I guess
people just it's trolling it's like
people want to troll more than anything
yeah what it is is you know especially
something like trousers Osiris when you
have that exclusive stuff lighthouse
it's some money-making thing to people
like you I can carry you to the
lighthouse you paid me this bread
you don't say dudes is doing it it's
it's it's dis out out - Wilhelm scream
in a chat bro stadia gang Manny got it's
399 broke me and Forte it
you already know what it is they can't
cheat over there it's a closed
environment it's lit so scream get that
free 99 every Time Lord card either says
free 99 I wanna I want one of the logos
in the chat because he's gonna say that
at least five six more yo fun don't be
hate you know my stadia you pocket
watching all my stadia Fox I see you
it's free 99 ain't no excuse for you not
to try it it's free that's all I'm sorry
friends but it's cool I'm a good wall I
saw it and it popped up on my jury moves
like you can join stadia for free right
now I was like I looked at it but you
know what it is my worry is it once you
sign up then to unsubscribe as hell bro
you sign up for the free Dinah stadium
doc I go to 399 right they give you the
pro version with all lay games you
accept this I want this I want that I
want all your games thank you thank you
thank you there you go right into the
account and cancel it and your credit
card is not charged you're two months
though you get the 2 months off rip talk
about cuz you can no longer eat at their
food source I want this over with
I gotta be honest you might be on to
something with it you know with the load
time certain matches you're saying you
know take a little minute you might go
to the loo you know that's far he talked
about you know you try to wait to get a
match
ok nobody we already established that
I've done my stadium finish out this
[ __ ] said about here selling it I could
be the Intellivision amigo it's true
about here push it but you like to do
that pretty much is doing that rock and
roll it but we got to get this poll
poppin you're missing so last week poll
results of dance but if again I gotta
get him to find out a super chat you
know it's
when people don't want your free stuff
down remember when the division came out
for two dollars and people was like it
could be free I'm the buddy bonds you
can access it got the cross play stop
spreading that misinformation for look
out look out extra he's being over this
talk to you you women man absolutely I'm
going to
does it matter called you know it's okay
cuz I'm gonna do that after we go to the
lighthouse company stream but it was
about winning the game that one game
that they got that is not on nothing
else
okay and what's funny is I bet you none
of them have touched that game no but
it's part of our package is part of my
stadia Pro that's the only reason the
gold we're there to try something that
you can't try anyplace else for the
lighthouse scream Pete map people go
flawless over this Aires that we had on
the show he fought us for stadia last
night news go for it and destroyed they
destroyed us they destroyed us no W dude
that you had ordinary yo it was crazy
before the math you want a fifth with
like I see some message pop up good luck
fellas
why this is why dude back him like oh
and they had the lighthouse emblems they
trial the Egyptian pharaoh I'm like oh
it's gonna be a loss my goal was the boy
y'all playing to stadia playgrounds it
was so bad it was so bad sinister was
like man you already had because they
already happening man yeah wheels like
why are you still here you already got
to the lapis hey get off the children
playground let us rock
[Music]
the Browning them the more stars off the
last poll results are ending the people
I've spoken to the question with the
recent release of Final Fantasy 7 remake
receiving mostly positive initial
reviews do you think part 1 of a remake
should be eligible for Game of the Year
awards
the winner of a fairly competitive
three-way IOP poll at 41% was yes Final
Fantasy 7 is a high-quality adaptation
and not just the remastered group don't
you love how he act like he didn't know
the results before no it's only a subset
of an incomplete game and in last place
at a close 23% was I don't care y'all
better keep that same energy resonate
with 2 & 3 great shout out to all the
lords who participate in the journey to
savage plans to go game is out here with
the template but I do see nice things
and I do hear nice things it's all boils
down to people's level of enjoyment and
how you spend to choose how you choose
to spend your money and enjoy your stuff
so god bless say less that's nice about
that stuff over there but I will never
give that game the goat when it has bare
bones from a relic that was years ago
when I was younger
yes yes sir yes again found out $10 -
Wow $10 a [ __ ] there's no option to turn
off cross play on xbox but it can be
done on PlayStation
there is cheap that is activated before
the game starts and the anti cheat
software can pick it up PC master-race
Microsoft really needs that make that a
man on PlayStation take it turn it off
they could turn it off you know why they
could probably turn it on children
they're protected
for yourself have that joint that
one-year exclusive so next year we'll be
able to turn it off - yeah I did hear
that it's so weird that place - I'll be
xbox you can't do it aren't you kid do
it but then you end up being in some
like super empty lobby where nobody
don't know about the hustle that you're
doing it ain't nobody to play with
kind of situation you in a lobby with
the real ballers in Machida's we gotta
get into these topics and all that good
stuff man so a first lord lot of
PlayStation news going on man with
what's popping in the world of
PlayStation 5 oh you talking about how
it's not gonna be free 99 it's rumored
that it's gonna be $4.99 it looks like
there's also going to be a shortage on
launch mm-hmm and there was something
else that I can't remember married well
here's the here's the big shot from the
Bloomberg report here the key points
from it it said all far fewer units of
PlayStation 5 in first year then
PlayStation 4 launch they sent up the
virus cuz I'm not gonna say the name
affected PR plans sony Sony may forgo a
press conference for ps5 release date in
price and their game devs anticipate a
500 to 549 price of a PS 5 and then also
a PlayStation 4 Pro and a basic play
city for a price cut is considered so
those are some of the major Tibbets did
you just say team i forgo a press
conference and release me but I think
that's the it's not stupid because the
obviously they're not having a press
conference with people there so I don't
really that mean I mean like a digital
like what does that sounds really
strange I'm just I'm very confused if
King is being sarcastic or it is good to
tell you like let's make no sense to me
what the hell are they talking about
like I want to see the Box displayed it
don't tell me
PlayStation 5 next year yes
what you get in the back in a baggie
well right the controller you just the
way there was no press conference for
that you know I'm saying it was
definitely that going oh so let's get it
to saw what do you think well let's go
the most interesting part about this is
when you read it closely they saying
that their production capacity isn't
affected at this point right
China's China's back up and running you
know they're gonna by June they should
be able to produce the amount of
consoles
that's that Sony would expect to produce
now what they're saying is that because
they cannot bring that price point to
what their base is accustomed to they're
off the RIP gonna make less consoles
because they think it's gonna sell less
yeah nothing to do with them beat not
being able to manufacture what they want
oh that's a bold statement article
what the hell what do you mean so you
yourself believe you're gonna piss
people off to the point they're not
gonna jump on the bandwagon because that
price point is not where they expect it
to be mm-hmm and so you're making less
as a result the same so let's see what
was shot the Bloomberg in him dudes he's
okay
Tokyo because they say they're limiting
their initial production run anymore
because it feels that the PlayStation 5
specs ambitious affects the way on
demand by leading is that a high price
at launch and of course we talk about
those parts you know say as far as the
access to that they said the the virus
has affected Sony's promotional plans
for the new device but not its
production capacity then they said the
company has told assembly partners it
will make five to six million units of
the piece the PlayStation 5 in the
fiscal year while Sony in for the play
the other PlayStation in 2013 it sold
7.5 million units in the first two
quarters so they definitely like you
said solve anticipating less and then
they said the last thing they said on
the game developer talking about on
components cost pushing up the price to
full require for Sony to break even sony
has struggled with its price setting
decision for the place of your fire
because of
as components so it is a agranov it does
feel self-imposed as far as you don't
know the amount of because it stopped
producing it is gonna be the issue but
don't welcome ask you this or what don't
you think as far as maybe because of the
climate of the virus and just the way
things are with the economy maybe they
saying to themselves you know we you
know we may need to pull back you know
it's good reference to that I'm gonna
tell you I'm gonna tell you this ah this
is Sony this is Sony you don't be many
people clamoring for the PS 5 right
regardless so you know whatever we don't
we say right but for the for the PS 5
it's going to sell like hotcakes no
matter what right um we already saw like
in this particular climate apart from
not making it difficult to complete
games and ship them out the desire for
gaming is grown exponentially just
because that's what I'm doing it so I
they're they're under estimating to me
what they could what they can sell it
did this self-imposed sort of like
airing back of what they can do there's
a sense because those those consoles are
not gonna stay on this they're not gonna
die on the shelf that's for sure what I
got move do you think that the reason
that they're doing what they're doing is
because of whatever they're doing to
build this they want to make sure they
meet quota so they're not over promising
anything that's the thing didn't we
would have to promise anything
but the fact that they've come out and
say but but they do at the low key tell
people you know if you want this oh it's
gonna be is gonna be a bloodbath when it
launches no matter what if they had 10
million out there at launch it was gonna
be a bloodbath Kate King king is the
king is the king of buying a Kennedys
yeah think about that and it even is one
that I'm a piece exactly so it doesn't
make any sense to me to me it seems like
they're hiding something they're not
saying something that it's happening on
the production line that it's slowing it
down a little bit because this feels
like a stupid reason
here you go I saw just a counter I just
want to say I mean we do got an epidemic
man it doesn't say like it's probably
maybe they said to themselves like look
if we put out all those I mean we feel
that they will sell out right whatever
they need you know they they put out
it's gonna sell like hotcakes right but
maybe you just like a little a slight
cautious thing from the standpoint of
look we don't know what's it did also
remember the retail aspect right right a
little bit really shut down right now
you know and I get that 100% but the
thing is if they had come out and said
that right that makes sense when they
come out and sick and when they come out
and say look it's basically a noteworthy
so this thing they're saying that
because we feel people are not gonna
find the price point appealing we're
gonna make less that's that's what the
reason they gave they didn't give up
he's in Barker onna but they said they
said because of the city the the the
constantly in flux situation with the
pandemic right and those numbers could
change they did say that right but their
reason for pairing back from the jump
mm-hmm the reason they gave is because
they feel that the price point is gonna
be unappealing and people won't jump on
this listen this thing is self-imposed
right this is what you do when you go
inside the bar you put the self-imposed
position on your wallet
I'm not going oh come on okay so it
everything about this this new Sony
seems budget all right now the only
reason why we are upset because we're
used to ball out Sony we used to Sony
coming in bowling um our logo just I
know my bad yeah all right so what I'm
seeing is and what I don't like what the
wording is first of all you don't got to
tell anybody anything cuz that's the
first part right there because all
you're gonna show inside in the week
list all right so you don't need to show
signs of weakness talking about ok well
the price will be from this range to
this range and we're not comfortable
stop lying your company you wanna you
want to take as much as you can take so
don't give me that don't give me the
price is too high for our consumer
that's a lie because you're the same
company that came out set $5.99 $6.99 on
these and I know we've went wrong for
the way anyway wrong and let's be real
one of the we you both agree Kate why
don't we know
Xbox bungled the Xbox one launch right
but we all of us on this on a bran
timetable agreed that it really did come
down to prices well one is four hundred
dollars at a better powerful system and
the other ones $500 or less powerful
that comes with the camera like it's not
rocket science so my thing is if they if
they had their best my point to you
cases if they had their best arguable
generation ever right with the
PlayStation 4 at a $400 price point
don't you think they would be more
inclined to want to try to reach that
and didn't being that now that the price
numbers are coming out as far as the
rest of the pattern and how scarce they
are and let's be real there SSDs are
scarce nobody nobody we have a LP and
the Samsung Galaxy phones and all I
mistaken listen everybody okay mmm-hmm
everybody oh shut up oh yeah oh yeah
under the Royal got shot the SWAT under
the wrong account your volume level is
low - I can't hear you hello you really
low hopefully you get in a situation
because a new challenger yeah alright so
it is this way right the components is
they am be promises a certain amount of
component right now and that's just a
CPU and a GPU but we also know that the
SSDs and other components is being made
from other you know companies right but
they know what a lot meant that they're
going to have okay right so Sony is
saying that we're going to throttle that
back the matter systems all right right
because of the simple fact that we can't
get it no no I agree we can ship product
routable back because of the
expectations of the price point and we
don't know the climate that are going
yes first let me tell you one thing
about this pandemic right there's a lot
of people out of work right now because
they can't go to work
but when there
to go back to work right all right those
jobs will be available now some jobs
won't be some jobs will be new jobs and
economy I start to kick in a little bit
later but what I'm saying is you can't
forecast your business model once
something that you don't know exactly
what's going to happen going ahead never
your business model was going forward
you want to achieve that those first
three months you want to sell as maximum
as possible because your competitor
that's going to be launching in the same
market as you is going to be trying to
get as much eyes as possible so when
you're saying this thing I don't really
understand the mentality and saying that
we're going to purposely produce less to
form a fake shortage that should not be
there you know this is like if Nintendo
told you their strategy this is
deliberate because that's what's gonna
happen
there's no be a shortage for no reason
but creates they do take rates like that
today I would say the fake demand or
whatever if that's the case does that
create animosity because you come on and
say I'll be have we confirmed like the
vibe I got I get I didn't I didn't get
every detail but you educate me honest
the vibe I got was this was
investigative reporting to find out like
that they didn't come out and say yo
this is what we're going this is when
certain snitches are saying that they
got inside that people are telling the
business to Bloomberg that's the vibe
our guy Bloomberg it's not you know it's
not it's night game crazy this is not
for Chan talk about the reputable
Bloomberg said come on say no no no no
we'll be producing as much as we
possibly can to make sure that you're
happy yeah so you know that means if
somebody tells you are you guilty or not
I'm gonna take the fifth wages not ready
to reveal their plans
okay I'm so sick and tired of people
giving these dudes a pass somebody
you're not phone you're not talking
right now they just really coy like how
much longer are we gonna let Sony go
quiet will thou be like something's up
we in the we am almost at the end of
April but they got to place these
affordable dominate console they don't
need to work on your town well you know
what's funny they they worked on my time
with the PlayStation 4 by now we knew a
lot more about the PlayStation 4 that we
do the 5 we know the controller funny
you know for a fact that this is a fraud
situation in progress and we need to
roll up with the lights on them and see
exactly what's going on I'm I'm not
gonna front I've heard me come out and
say now usually dude say we're gonna
have a shortage you know we tried to
produce as much I haven't heard of
something a secret come out and say they
gonna purposely throttle it back we make
sure that what happens a little tinny
under the Christmas tree they didn't get
a PlayStation cuz even Sony said not for
you
shut up to us to the torus which a
PlayStation 5 dead on arrival at 5:50
thoughts oh yes that's a high that's
higher then we had oh shut up tube rap
basically video arcade podcast mm or
some loot base but radio arcade and all
Christopher Hart for you King 2000s Sony
will be walking on water with the
PlayStation [ __ ] yo you'll be walking on
water to go get one because he overseas
just make sure that you got your
passport ready Freddy so he [ __ ] on
their plane gotta get Smitty Smith
mm-hmm we got a $10 super track from
Smitty so it
gentes booth Ryan who's that on this
Summer Jam scream wearing a tutu momo
Smitty Smith
oh that's Chris Hart gym dirty move Ryan
I've been looking for a new dance
partner Smitty Smith I bet you had
that's a savage Oh what about say this
is the official statement no they also
said in conjunction with that which was
basically that they said the production
value could still change they said
depending on the virus situation sony
has asked employees to work from home to
mitigate the spread of the virus in its
it it's board has been unable to meet
and approve business plans for the
current fiscal year including nodes for
the PlayStation unit the meeting was
originally supposed to take place in
March Sony said last month that it plans
to release results for the year Oh
billionaires millionaires the board
can't get together and guess what we
can't get together the same that the
promotional plans were thrown into into
but everybody play according to the the
virus has already up in this Sony's
promotional plans the company may forgo
hosting a public press conference for
its PlayStation 5 release date and price
unveiling unveiling due to infection
fears public press conference makes a
hundred percent sense yeah just do a
digital thing yes Ferrell recently it
was forced forced to reveal the dual
sensation file control in a hurry
how okay so does that though I said you
you so you shared it with developers
outside of Sony so your partners as well
people that have a vested interest in
secretive as long as possible and trust
them like so everyone what does that
have to do with
let's just say to me they were lost a
day they had you know the fire is
hitting hard which McCollum instagrams
love to have their nudes leaked and in a
habit so they just leave them from
Stahl's so they get ahead or bleeker's
know what I mean this is when you get
your butt whip you under your big
brother
he said that's real about the board
meeting King he says zoom is insecure no
way they would discuss that one a zoom
or use Microsoft teams Microsoft is not
having conference calls on a phone
sitting there talking about that we can
meet in person it's actually low-key
it's like it's like Saudi acted like
they drug dealers right no we can't say
that on the phone we need certain things
man we can't just come straight out and
say something to the home you're a
psycho cave and that's my dude Jack Jess
we wanted to say okay there you go just
what to say share some of that stimulus
check to one of the best podcast of the
gays salute y'all what was you gonna say
just like you said adding they do it
like it's a drug transaction like I
don't see you I die we are not doing
this deal you know and I know is this
Microsoft is moving in the same space
but they do having the same I feel like
this is just a cop-out you
it feels weird and I get it that it's
not directly from them but like I said
it's Bloomberg it's then publish tell
you what they heard like they definitely
got that like you said it's a gay in
crazy oh we got royalty in the realm
right that's the husband of the year
I'll be sure to good to have you in so
are you listening to all this banter was
going over PlayStation 5 and in the
reports for Bloomberg did you get a
chance to see any that stuff or you need
me to send it to you well
what's your feeling man I think they had
a lot to go on they they'd be shouting
influence ops I don't know if you're
gonna walk on water we got to get this
super jet Oh shout out to the JD tamer
final a super chat price is so important
every generation if PlayStation 5 fails
at price what could be effect be and
would we even be having this
conversation
launched at 399 interested yet price is
important prices a poll every week we
have heard that they are willing to um
kind of wait and see what Microsoft is
doing as far as I think they know that
marker sauce willing to adjust and
because if one of your technical which
don't know the price of of the Xbox
series X and it's look like the S is
about to get now so let's put that into
consideration we're gonna have the s and
the X reveals before the PS 5 is really
like eating in person so we got mad
super chance we got cool with God you I
to catch up help me out that's albums
cool with the $5 so but at Microsoft has
custom tools that they built that they
know that they can trust and are secured
Sony is way behind a proprietary
collaboration software that is for sure
cool that's for sure but that's of them
problems
Blumberg out here acting like Takashi
they just report the news but they'd
like a nobody up there just do that yo
yeah I gotta get these super shout out
to Mariano pump fo with the three
dollars to purchase Tony should use
their peers five yo taxi disrespectful
you go up set the bike a bullet down
Shola so they gotta use that for the
cards go you disrespect we we got ten
dollar super jet from Philly Eagle no
disrespect intended to anyone but they
are wording it that they were that the
way because they know they are stupid
people who would believe it if they said
the sky isn't blue just more bullish
firm Wow
restored Haley stork rest up finest of a
check growing up Sony is always been the
aggressive I know you all remember the
crash trailers with him standing outside
Nintendo asking Mariota fax you right
idiot it I will sit thinking sorry king
and solves defense yes it does feel out
of character to see them on their heels
solve you got to get brat he's up next
sellout tube wrap with the Fabio super
chat though Spencer also said the plan
is to launch series X holiday 2020 but
that there are no guarantees that
happens recent BGR article that is true
no to be honest with you he said
software yeah I don't know Brad if you
listen to the UM the unlocked interview
nope he got cuz I shot the Ryan
McCaffrey and he's actually was on the
show before um he challenged fill-in the
way I never seen he was like look if it
come down to the hardware and halo
infinite you know I'm saying and I feel
kind of he said was like look the
manufacturing stuff is coming up online
we don't anticipate anything now he did
say we handle infinite but he kind of
alluded that look if it's not ready
we're not gonna force out a game but the
vibe is the
odd where's common you know say that
pressure he gave let me just also say
this he knows that he has that cyberpunk
2077 so for so he can actually say the
game that is so highly anticipated there
we're making on our we're not gonna
force that out the door just to meet
hardware and that would if he ever did
that and that game flops this is where
his legacy is on this is his launch so
when you say that uh-oh
they said they may not know Brad we
gonna let you roll that all right no I
think I think that that had alternative
motives like oh the same all he said is
it there's no guarantees it was a does
agree with her you know I have I have to
call it man in that interview he said he
was very confident he was said if any
he's like he was like that the consul's
is extremely ahead of schedule like we
even ever Ella to take a home project
right now with them he's like if
anything gets canceled or delayed it's
the software Eddie you just see the Box
in the we gotta get the range II fall
asleep a chest sony sony may have
triple-a games in the work it works and
waiting until it's finish to show out
off that loss I hear you rained but the
only thing is the Bloomberg report
doesn't really allude to that like it
seems like it's just it's it's different
man it's a lot of other things going on
you know infrastructural rise and we
just got to figure it's like I said man
we passed a pre passed the middle of
April we still don't know anything very
much and just like that the article said
they were forced to show us the
controller now you got put you got a boo
who did that for
who did that for you don't know we get
the Burnie have another ear conference
here we go photic rest up for the day's
to the Sony fans I can't you can't
exhibit auntie Saab days you out of
control right now this is a good one um
I don't know man I mean I will say this
yes we have and here's Cognito with the
middle ground stae i say i don't know
it's okay kid cuz we got solve on assist
over the same page I'm just saying I
don't know what's going on I will agree
yes it looks shaky a little different
than the Sony I'm used to it absolutely
but I can't go crazy only for one reason
I go crazy go crazy you know what I'm
gonna go crazy
well I'm gonna go crazy if June they
release bargaining giucose bah and we
still don't got enough you'll say like
Jul to me is my internal cut off right
okay so we're on 3 June III Joel yes oh
the normal time that we will know yeah
like if they are quiet during that
period then they're getting the fraud
alert emoji from me to get in the
concern like what's going on like at
that point you gotta be in production
you I'm saying you got to start moving
and grooving so all I'm you got good at
the fraud alert I like that I'm starting
to be convinced that the you know that
the PS 5 even maybe the series X but the
you know what Microsoft seems to be a
little bit more confident when it comes
to the series X coming out because
they've actually made comments have
showed what the console looks like I'm
starting to think that
the ps5 might be delayed to 2021 like
I'm pleased with you he takes both
castles could be Oh
I'm not believing in braaap with that X
I already know come hello Hodja bro
that's the advantage Microsoft has
because Microsoft is focusing more on
game passing the ecosystem right the
games are gonna be there right even if
the infinite isn't in it isn't there
right you're still gonna have to be if
the machining for whatever rings it
doesn't make it out to see which I don't
believe is gonna happen I think it's
just the fact that the ecosystem is what
matters
yes paradise with me and you want to say
in pain that's where I'm with y'all Phil
Phil is prepared that to me
they already they have shown that that
really is yeah during a crisis they
appear to be the better prepared company
they based on what we're seeing as far
as the rollout as far as the marketing
as far as all these things and he
doesn't see the level of transparency is
so much like that they just took me when
I see that it's like a kid that's
prepared for the test you don't know
with a school Tom he like you know I
still gotta study in you know say no you
don't get to see cuz he's trying to
study he's he's scrambling you know to
do something nice dude it's like yeah
I'm ready wasn't Wednesday Wednesday
yes yes I completely agree I think what
it is is 2013 showed it actually talked
up a harsh lesson I agree with Kings
point that this is his launch completely
from a detached from the old
infrastructure as far as deterrence is
the dahle metrics and all that stuff you
know he said on our Ryan McCaffrey thing
that he had to UM build morale up during
his leadership reign so I think that you
know they said to themselves I think
King of Kings own something I think that
what they said to themselves is to three
things one transparency let everyone
know what's going on - we can't lose the
power narrative right three was solve a
scene we're gonna push services X cloud
all that stuff so actually that kind of
approach must deserve
a nice cloud stuff really is conducive
to a client that I've been to a climate
that is going through an epidemic like
this right where heart hardware is hard
to get the retail could be stymied they
are moving and grooving because their
model kind of alludes better it to that
type of climate whereas Sony is kind of
the more traditional you know to bring
more to the stores and and getting it
out there and I just always because
we're seeing that they need to be all in
one room to make a decision and when you
all have to get together to make a
decision and you're waiting for the old
auditor to allow you to get to work yeah
while other people are still moving
listen what I've just noticed is
Microsoft is doing probably three
different launches in one year and these
dudes can't get one launch together
right you talking about X cloud rolling
out right because they do it Chris cloud
now if you don't think that's a rollout
and that launched they doing the soft
launch and everybody right now and they
build an infrastructure and linking that
to the game pass and allowing you to be
pitas got a point and then they're
talking about the s then they're talking
about the X mmm why can't you just get a
controller and a system out why can't
you live what's going on you remember
when they were talking about um when
they were talking about supply chains
might be stymied by the fact that the
taxes coming out of China and all that
stuff were a bit that was an issue right
and immediately you saw that Microsoft
pivoted and said oh we have contingency
plans for that man we're manufacturing
the Philippines or something like that
um so they already exactly they had
contingency plans for production right I
I think Microsoft a like look like
regardless what happens we're gonna have
to throw if even if we have to throw
money yet if it's a possible scenario or
this does not get delayed if we could
stop it we're doing that let's get to so
much as we are behind optimist grovyle
silver Chet there is a whole chapter on
custom collaboration tools in the book
of Esther super chair from Stitch Sony
don't know what's going on
call we got a $2.00 super chat from
Smitty submit October's code is on to
something yes start on to something come
up there right out of all I got you got
a range e for $2 super chat Sony has the
tower of soured oh I got a $5 super chat
from I am not pronouncing so no yeah
that's definitely not a that's not a
white thing I can
so what could Microsoft do to for Sony
to show something if not everything got
a $2.00 superchef rangy for you need a
permit to buy your hats off has all
their ducks in a row they are prepared
the book IMAX what can a Microsoft do to
make Sony come outside um you're about
to see in me you you're about to see the
smack now like you you ever been
watching wrestling you get that dominant
Restless that just running through and
he's yelling out who's next shout out
the Hobart um
he's looking like Goldberg right now and
I'm wanting to tailor it back a little
bit because sometimes when you win too
hard and people start to root against
you right what do you know about scope
yeah no no I like the dominance I like
how everything is going let these dudes
come out and then smack them back I
think I dig his thing is that this by
theory I believe that the Lockhart will
be something that they uses a
reactionary method I there's a lot of
chess in gamesmanship mm-hmm that I feel
is going on and I think that they have
allocated you know but what surprised me
too your defense is when they said you
know when I read in the Bluebird report
that they hurried the control out why
are you hurrying anything out why aren't
you ready for that so I gotta agree with
y'all on that point on that part and I
read stuff like that that concerns me
I'm like but that should be what
Microsoft did right after they released
they control the joint what they showed
the controller for the cyberpunk they
leaked that out
oh you know I do have a question for you
guys I know it's not a topic but you
know from the whole website thing
flashing what do you guys think that
that's gonna be they've already that's
go tomorrow that is tomorrow I thought
they've already revealed with the cyber
console you guys know it's a comeback
and or days it's not been for days yeah
no I I think that's the gameplay trailer
okay because remember mark off as the
marketing rights for the game so I was
like the gameplay trailer because
remember we haven't seen anything else
since that's that you saw that I was so
telling about that you better be able to
the eyes owned by his self in the corner
shout out the CD Projekt RED for
blessing Lord gave me that nasha of the
gene in the chat floor gene from non
Lords gave me that I said yes it leaked
and I think Lord Mahmoud was the one
that's my brother right they put that up
on Lords of game with that necks up
there right now you can see the console
oh I don't like the design
I like the controller alright this is a
but I heard this console games on the
dog you know I'm saying so like I'm not
buying it I can take this I will get
that controller yeah loan in the dark
that scare me now the question is is
that council going to be $300 you wanna
you wanna switch topics and roll right
into it it's gonna be pretty us what's
the topic with the with the little light
things all right all right
super chance we gotta get JD gaming with
the final of super chat don't forget
that Microsoft is launching a dual
screen phone later this year might not
need a controller with that one to play
X cloud and all-in-one devices to play
in their ecosystem Medi Smith with the
fire dollar super chat Microsoft is like
World War Hulk
Sony don't want no parts of this combat
[Laughter]
and then shout out oh you want me to get
it shout out the spoon man with the file
on a super chat hashtag in field Dominus
we trust
hello boys been in a while fact I got it
I got a hit you with the field ominous
one that low-mass cool man salute
haven't seen you in a minute that's for
something so we'll stay on order cuz
cake has a lot to clearly husb you know
for this so home yeah man so what's
going on we got a lot of switched on
what's what's going on King you excited
what's going on I like I like when you
set it up okay yes so
our knowledge you don't say as far as
this way there's some rumors that's
going on I want to shout out believe the
gentleman is Mike head skin and on what
happened is there's a lot of real
basically actually switch boy your skies
with the switches got your firm firmware
10 point Oh came up
so with this firmware and I believe
homeboy is a vulnerability researcher
aka a professional but a home so look
like you're in this data mind he found
out that there is a new model switch
it's definitely confirmed in there it's
the NX - something-something ABCD and
apparently this model has evidence of a
secondary display exclusively for this
model so this is data mind information
from this 10-point no firmware um leaked
so get kick I'm just gonna give it back
to you I know you brought it to my
attention I did not know about any of
this because I have in place which a
little bit but um well what you thought
process man it's your topic it lives are
you I will take this I will just this
give me a clamshell swimming way we are
you say King switched coming in hot
the boy did you just read it did you
just not get big of mine and they just
told you that listen it makes perfect
sense to be honest with you he says it's
coming up and I don't know how to hell
this switch has been keeping evening
chicken if not running circles around
the Xbox and Sony with the same games
now some of them might be a little bit
buddy but these games so they know for
sure they cannot keep pace with these
new systems and I think this is the next
evolution in that but I've missed the
double screen like I miss my arm 3 yes
yes so so now that I get the double I
will get clammy why I like the double
screen I need to hit it you were three
years guy right please explain to me why
you love this double screen the map Oh
back of the Yap I need it for B to make
a hat so my question is why did y'all
like that I just wanted a what some
whole appeal raised on that show
Nintendo joints the the pocket literally
grew up a little baby bass FIFA bet the
little static screen it yeah the double
trade yeah you right
send me to the store to go pay the phone
bill and I was going across the street
and lo and behold I saw the you know
that the game is on he shoots the the
smoke up in the air so it was like a
plant game something like that and it
was a dual screen and I went in and I
paid half for that on the phone wow wow
I was the best guy yeah you know why cuz
they went to the store she went to you
took me right back to store the game was
like yo how could you sell this to a
child about none of that stuff there's
no returns and no refunds my mom play it
she gonna have to get that over the B's
yo let's get let's get smarter here man
so the opposite is firmware rumor you
know I'm saying about the switch now I
believe the 3ds era and all that stuff
so how do you feel about this firmware
date of mind
seconds dual screens no switch I like
the Wii U I'm a little nervous about
like I kind of I wanted to show what it
is yet more than just like mm-hm being
data minded being talked about like oh
this is what it's gonna be right because
honestly what I what I'd much rather
prefer is a switch with like a six out I
feel that then you know one have a
longer battery to do one yeah that long
enough don't we angry but it is better
it's better yeah yeah okay so guess what
so that's that's me that's mainly your
point on this yeah I mean I like the on
the Wii U and on even on the 3ds like
there are some games that utilized it
well but at bad times it felt a little
gimmicky with the certain games like
yokai watch I remember being in it I
just didn't like how aggressive you had
to scrape on the springs I don't want to
discuss this watch that's why you you
said that you were like a longer battery
life what if because of the dual screen
they able to put an extra battery inside
and they do give you that six to eight
hours of battery life with the rules
screen with that I'll probably end up
buying it because even with a lot of the
newer consoles coming out I don't really
know what what I want to buy cuz they're
looking more and more like pcs yeah
I already have a came to you so you know
you're not really impressed and also I
mean with the whole game pass thing I
can I can play all the Xbox games on my
PC Phil dominus Maximus princess sir
soon to be Aurelius it it is a great
program from the words of Swat yes yes
but I don't know if God if you ever want
to know about the crest which we always
throw up in the chats know that Lord
SWOT is the original creator he's the
bass designer for the original logo they
shout at the devil proneural
for the extra sauce on it we got to
shout you out of that so because people
ask me all the time dad logo that logo I
was like I swapped this one kid gave him
the directive anything pulled through
we broke bread wheezy and sushi Sabbath
to somebody that said King you gotta eat
some sushi and when we went to the
restaurant to go okay I can't help these
Hillbillies right so we go out to go to
go get some sushi because we use that
III we want to eat it was me I'm a panda
man so we get nice sushi for the night
what a we and that's what she was really
good to my remote right so we order some
sake all three of us right so they
brought our sake I mean soir sake and
it's filled the top they brought hot
sake out and it wasn't all the way up to
the top and I was like what the hell is
going on full of crest up right quick
Victor Alice they filed a super check
marks off needs to have x1 Tech in their
phone to compete with the switch
negatively and shout out to you guys
should have the dawn as a guest book of
X salute yes you'll to those guys man -
darling I'm God
yeah I mean if they come out with a
phone like that absolutely yeah I think
Microsoft's done with phones
maybe you got one coming really like a
3d X this is gonna have the software of
the it's gonna have X cloud doping is
gonna happen and and when you get that
phone baby oh let's get you come from
that era are you excited about a dual
screen switch I don't care just give me
bravery default the next hour I'll buy
it like oh you would pick it up I mean
if that's the only way I could play
these
James yeah just watch turn your minds at
me Loeb oh sorry sir
what if they released light load Leary
poured it in the we you win waker HD Oh
would you buy would you buy one then it
just if I can only play it on that
device I would but if I can play it on
the switch it's on right now then I
wouldn't I probably wouldn't buy it
and I think the way I still have an S so
you know to do that if he ain't got a he
ain't gonna do screen switch are you
excited I think I mean I don't know
about excited but what I will say is
this it feels like and I'm hopefully I'm
right but I don't know this is a
Nintendo we're talking about like going
to do a screener out there trying to
unify they obviously they've realized
that they're still gonna sell plenty of
two years three years they're gonna sell
plenty of those right but my hope is
that they're finally realizing that they
need to unify this ecosystem as much as
possible under the switch banner um and
that's my hope right that you'll be able
to play these 3ds games on this new dual
screen switch in addition to games
coming out for the switch moving forward
we'll have that option where you can use
like like I said the second screen for
like a map or something like that
because it's I mean again it's like
anything it doesn't have a dual screen
you're always gonna be playing the
fleshing that like the select button to
go to your map or whatever the 3d has
just made that it just made it easier
you just have it always in front of you
and it was you can do different things
with that second screen it's it is game
changing per se but it's a move that
makes it feel like they're looking at
then their ecosystem more as an
ecosystem and maybe and this is wishful
thinking maybe then they'll be gouging
you less for your money do you think
that this system replaces the
the dart system it could be right they
were saying something about how the how
the code names indicate that it's it's a
hybrid system or the codes it leads them
to believe one is a hybrid one is like a
standard console one is straight up
portable right depending on how it's
it's it's lettered and numbered so I
believe this one is supposed to be
hybrid again where it's portable and
additionally it can be plugged into a
dock so if that is the case yeah I think
maybe the original the og straight-up
just dock version kind of gets phased
out this will be the new hybrid and then
you still have the light as your
straight-up portable did you know how to
scratch their screens by you making it a
clamshell you just put the clamps and
then you normal crackers plug them yeah
another thing right forget about the
dock right if you're not gonna put
actual power in the dock they can forget
about the dock you just give me the HDMI
port on the machine itself first of all
nobody like the joint just laying in
there like that again if it's for you if
it's nice and protected and folded it's
a little thing not to itself I can do
that cake stand is in the bush that's
the phone kickstand okay presentation no
no no clam show let's get a little
Douglas make it look nice please do
intend to are without that either it
folds both ways right because you want
the screen on the outside no no no no I
want to close like but you just want to
be able to stand it up I want you to
walk in my house and be like what's that
like that what I'm saying like if it's
laying in his next year TV take pitches
nice jet they Ted no only doing this to
resell you 3ds games I think you order
something with don't kill the three day
I saw it's gonna have virtual console
and y'all gonna shut up just to bring
this up I mean anyone remember like the
original DS is they used to come with
the support for the advanced games you
know Nintendo has done it before where
they have one console I can take two
different types of games so it could be
a possibility games but my question like
you know things I wonder is I mean
that's that's you bringing it back a lot
just to have like a really low res
version of games not really all that
like we're talking about switch not
being graphically powerful okay can can
not the 3d it was kinda hard to look at
we can we admit that you know maybe this
isn't supposed to be like a new
iteration of the switch is just like a
switch that is a little bit different to
get the asses in the 3d I mean like if
you add the three BS
accessibility to this you just you just
increased the library like tenfold
alright I already see what's going on
and for me look man this is hard
evidence I'm disgusted
yes I'm disgusted tonight I know you're
happy this is that I'm not about this
this is not hot this is that's much come
play hard to beat this was powerful
what it is the only caveat but we don't
go do that I don't think I don't think
that I think that's what this is is I
think that they're going to kill the 3ds
out they've not made the announcement
they're like look like you switch orders
like I get it here's a switch that's
backwards compatible you know 3ds games
when we kill it you have to switch games
and you have the 3ds games I'm not
hanging I'm just saying if they don't
got no power fidelity
but it in any way yes yes actually a
little switch with the second screen I'm
all-in
I want to onto something actually I come
to think of it if they did that I would
buy if I had access to the 3ds be a
Walmart
I'll be at Walmart looking for something
to play on the switch and like all the
hot stuff is on the is on the 3ds and
I'm like man like stuff it's the same
man talk about 480i on the games I'm
playing the he told me the same graphics
you beg to be myself I said it has to be
compatible to 3ds games fraud alert on
poor you have you played all the Swiss
day and there's no power happening but
you excited cuz you ain't getting no
power that you got later you mean to
pray about it yeah everything everything
I'm getting a second okay a new mirror
I'm getting a new mirror on my claim I'm
excited to go King every time we've
talked about the switch what's the one
thing I say I buy the switch for its
exclusives I don't care about third
parties
oh that and then the power what about
the power down now you don't care about
the look your games right this is what
this does me I got mad 3ds games
upstairs right and if like that extends
you know I mean I gotta win the fun or I
will put it up on you because this is
real but now that you got a switch that
could actually switch up and do
something different you know God forbid
us want to play 3s games you know
they're the same man every show why you
want to play
games it's the worst version of the game
but they get it they barely know we're
talking about 3ds we're talking about
the platform that has all the pokemon
games we're talking the platform is a
black graphics with the same way with
the same graphics you complain about you
popping bottles for this you know why
i'm popping bottles for this cuz I don't
gotta buy no games I got me games
upstairs I could just actually play my
games now all in one union so I got my
switch I got my 3d upset on this start I
buy this switch for its first party
stuff so mister said imma give you
everything in one box cam fullscreen
like you like it cuz you like had a two
joint jump off thank you thank you Joe I
appreciate it
isn't it maybe up I don't know maybe
they do something make me yeah I don't
know about kpop I'm bit I've always been
repaired about I'm like look I have a
computer I have an Xbox I have a place
they should follow to play those other
stuff I play it on there when you talk
about when you talk about a third party
game on the switch I said yo I got it on
my I need y'all to put $4 lights or if
you had never made fun of anybody
playing a third party based on physics
as proposed as opposed to the other
consoles you'd be in the clear but every
time you have the opportunity to make
fun of somebody by the thing is on the
switch I've always said I played for its
first party explosions I don't know what
you guys play on your third Cory can
show us you talk about their buddy say
why we playing it you had to drive
though
there's a difference between me joking
and me being serious and you guys know
don't care would you guys play on your
switch yes you do cuz you got something
to say yeah when I picked this time
listen listen to this watch how I cite
them even further when you guys started
talking about playing all the 3d library
I was like you know what that all the
sodas are on there the games are coming
in are you excited for this I said to a
mirror on top of the joint and you
pumped I get it I get it
listen now all that MPD talk all that
coming in hot I'm coming in just go by
system and I'm just throwing mirror on
top of this fire yes I'm good when you
put up your switch you'll be like haha
I'm gonna do the same thing with the
class how would that even look if a
switch had two screens awesome is going
to look McManus
yelling why are you why does it matter
if my mic what is this man fraud second
screen now oh is this what his attic
world is what he care about now is fire
like what if somebody else get about he
no care moving on anyway nothing about
new screens and all that other stuff of
my whole life I wanted to do exactly
what it'd be super super jet shout out
to the hard evidence quote-unquote Lord
Connie dough is on to something and then
we have smoothy spoof again with the
five out super jet I must and will stand
with Lord Cognito and the cognitive beat
with the file super chat hashtag I stand
with God meanwhile King is sitting back
like a genius with all the chaos crystal
had it you frogs turn off a mic moment
in quite some time
I don't know how addict is the only more
fraudulent in the situation with me and
both have the same stance
I knew doing funny things that have the
exact same stance because you the same
the exact same throw that fraud alert
for kingpin is I don't find it I just
know why you fight is it just funny
what he loves oh he just is it is what
it is but if I love it I'm gonna
purchase it I'm gonna have mad fun
I want no my biggest question is well
they have the more of them ready before
the PlayStation 5j bunny with two outs
of a check could you play a dual-screen
dot handheld only that's a good question
it is if it is kind of the replacement
for the bass switched like I was saying
like the clamp clasp the clamshell makes
it do two things right it makes it even
more portable by which makes it even
more appealing to younger kids because
no matter how kitty this switch light
feels and it's still kind of vague in
comparison to what you would see get
from a 3d or something like that so
making it a clamshell me see that much
more portable and it consolidate all of
that and actually put like I said the
HDMI connection on there are you guys
done yes which then coalfire superjet I
don't abide this Attucks lambda white
boy got skills
[Laughter]
Nintendo is continuously figuring out
ways to make to spend your money again
and again and again I can't even be mad
at them because they're just the masters
they really are and people do with a big
smile on their face and then we got
velvet lulu with the $5 super chat glad
to see a fight that was good
anyway so uh Lord sovereign king that
ignited all type of beef today so uh
Louis saw you are up xbox Lockhard
what's going on man everything's yeah so
over the past week and a half or so
close to two weeks
um Xbox themselves officially dropped
the price of the Xbox one X to $300 and
the speculation around that is and
actually the price has gone back up in
certain regions but overall it's $300
all the way around and that's for a base
system or that's for a bundle system so
you can get one with a hot design and
controller which it recorded a game
installed already like there's all kinds
of bundles out there that are going for
straight-up $300 so the thinking around
that is that the speculation around that
is that they are clearing out Xbox 1x
stock in preparations and bringing it
down to this price point in preparations
for revealing what we all know to be as
a Lockhart ass / Xbox series s console
and shout out to friend of the realm
Randall for for expounding on this uh
this topic yesterday in the video yeah
and good video definitely take a look at
that but um the speculation around it is
around price right so thinking is if you
bring down the X the 1x to $300 and in
hopes of clearing out the stock then
you're sort of preparing the market for
a successor at that price point which is
something that I said from the beginning
I said don't briefs if they really want
to win put that whatever that Lockhart
as cheap as possible $300 is super cheap
um so that speculation that that the
series X will be around that price point
that's one and then - it sort of lends
credence to the fact that we may see it
sooner rather than later
obviously filters come out and said that
the expectation for June and whatever
the replacement for e3 is gonna be is
still going to be focused on games so
we've we've heard speculation that there
will be two sort of events coming up one
in May one in June so the assumption is
the one in May is the full on console
reveal everything
the console and perhaps the series s
reveal oh well even people that at that
secondary option if they don't want to
go with the super high-end option so
this is super interesting to me in in
lieu again sort of when you think about
the apparent issues and struggles that
Sony is having with price point um and
what they want to do with their console
and if this is true it puts Microsoft in
a position of strength at the launch and
in it's funny because for a long time I
said to myself I don't know about
releasing two SKUs at launch I don't I
don't really know you know you could
possibly hurt yourself but what
Microsoft really focusing on their
ecosystem above and beyond everything
else it kind of doesn't matter it kind
of doesn't matter what matters is that
hopefully the games are there but they
give him people so many options to enter
the ecosystem that I think there's only
strengthens what they're trying to do so
what do you guys think um obviously you
know we're hearing that you know
obviously the point we saw was saying as
far as the larger stuff like that and
then in reference to you know a lot of
the price cutting that we're seeing you
know say as far as the sales and stuff
like that you know so I'm not gonna
frame your thought but what do you feel
about what he said and these are these
potential moves
Americus often referenced it is I think
it's a really good but I mean I'm no
marketing expert so I'm not I'm not sit
here and critique that but I think
they're they're just trying to make like
cast a wide net and make sure that they
have the options available for everyone
to jump into if they just want to if
they just want to play games on console
or if they want the best you know
experience on Xbox with the series X or
right if they just want to you know jump
on with with game pass ultimate hmm play
from their PC I think that's or even
just on their phone with the X cloud so
it's like you know they they're focusing
I think a lot on the games and just
making sure that those are available and
I think that's really awesome note let
me get the switch after we get panicked
if he's still talking Oh
Mads gaming with the tennis which our
brother from Lourdes gaming dotnet the
tech guru no need for Xbox one X if Xbox
Lockhart
is real $300 in my opinion so he feels
that he's definitely gonna be 300 act
are you there sir on what do you give
you about the look before we get into
attics point yes now this this is
something that I struggled with right
and I understand why why why not make
your top of the line right the new base
base line right okay rather than
eliminate the X and then have the super
low sha day or whatever the s whatever
be the new date right why not have your
top of the line be the new base and for
me as a consumer I think that would make
that makes more sense now from the
business standpoint I understand why it
doesn't work because at the end of the
day the X having been the the premium
control for this long right for three
years now at this point more people have
bought shadows more people have bought
essence all the way overall then then
the X right so it makes more sense that
you don't you don't sort of push those
other people out of the ecosystem and
tell them well if you want to be at the
baseline of this ecosystem moving
forward you're gonna need to get an X if
they haven't gotten one yet
so I get that but I don't know like it
just feels weird that you wouldn't have
your top of the line become the new
bottom in encounter to your point
don't you think because they still
haven't revealed the Lockhart
there'll be we do it because we the hard
core that it exists but be great effect
it technically it's just been in an Xbox
Series X marketing push the public
doesn't even know about the you know the
what's up to the cars going by what's
gonna put home they don't even know
about the series s so to speak you know
I'm saying that right they'll kind of
like that hillbilly came up to New York
[Laughter]
you don't think that that state things
let's get out of here
that but that's the thing though that I
definitely get that well if this is the
case right why eliminate the X rather
than the s right you mean oh you mean
like the whole that old s and the old
I'm talking about the one X right why
why discontinue the one X and not the s
and then maybe one X both no well
this is really this is really talking
about the X I write that because that
the chalet and and the 1s have really
been no down in terms of price they've
been shaped for a while abt forward
first time that you really had a
sustained drop in price for the 1x right
so being that there's speculation that
whatever stock is there is getting
pushed out and that's it and you're not
gonna get replenishment then the
assumption is that the 1x is what's
getting phased out completely and
discontinued yeah give my but I think I
think the X just continue this is gonna
get discontinued just like the original
Xbox got discontinued when the S came
out and it's just going to be the
x-series X and series s on on the
shelves I'm sorry get it oh yeah
they I think they learned their lesson
but the whole thing with having the two
ecosystems like what Brian's been
talking about with the haven't looked at
360 when they released a 360 and not
released at 36 but at least the one and
they were telling people oh stick with
the 360 for for a while because we're
still gonna have games on that right I
would like you know people get upset by
that
mm-hmm so I don't think they're gonna
try to release a market where they're
telling people oh just keep buying the
old console right we're still supporting
it for another year right
I think they'll just try to be like yeah
that one's that one's phasing out that's
the new stuff under standard there's a
similar price point with yes another I
know the forward compatibility I could
see that I completed we almost like a
replacement per line cuz just jump into
two before I go to cake
I think the es in the ex solve remains
standards for them from a marketing
standpoint the S represent there's a you
know low budget you know but still have
good performance and then the hardcore
connoisseur has the ex if he wants to go
all the way out with the power he's get
the super chat right quick he got on
gene actually no we had mastered then we
had gene walk Louis to LA super chat
caught we'll run circles around the 1x
and somebody gotta get squirrely dead in
Canada pull out some Jack squirrely
dan80 - what - to us we check but the
one x can keep can't keep up with the
new s I think when it comes to these
consoles my opinion because I think
they're gonna have a little bit of hard
time marketing to different consoles and
you know - different plate people I
think that the whole point of the S is
to obviously appeal to the casual market
and the X is to appeal to the hardcore
market yes so I think they're going to
probably promote the s more than the X
yeah well shout out to set out to random
K R and he says I think the 1s will
stick around as the cheapest entry point
for the Xbox ecosystem they can sell
them for 149 to 199 while the series s
will be $2.99 in section and and from a
business standpoint I do understand that
because you figure that the that the 1x
and still has to be fairly expensive to
produce especially more so than the s
right right so if you are gonna
eliminate one that you're gonna
eliminate the one that's gonna cost you
more to make up at at you know on the
production actually agrees with you saw
he thinks that the S is staying around
and that it's gonna be almost but they
are very clear at their support let's
get King in honest man wait what you
feel about this whole immediate rumors
and all this stuff like our shout out to
ran I did watch the video - yes sir um
and I definitely put that like on it
okay so let me give you a business 101
ready
so y'all was asking me how can they make
Sony make moles right this is how you
mix only make moves when you took your
your most powerful system and you make
that three 299 right 300 bucks you
brought that down now you're getting a
price that price set in people head
right so when a consumer goes to the
store they know that it's $2.99 right
they know Microsoft has this at 299 now
I do believe that they keep the S there
for that low entry that low entry part
and I do that believe that the series s
I do believe that they're gonna phase
out the X right that's gonna get phased
out
the series s and the S the Xbox one s
those are going to be the moneymakers
right those are gonna be the ones that
they can actually make money off of so
how much it costs for the series s to be
produced
I believe that it'll be $50 more they
make $50 per unit now the costs on the
regular Xbox one s is going to be
dropped down but they're still making a
profit off of each box right and I think
they can take a loss on the X and
subsidize all of that with the ecosystem
this is where they're uniquely different
and diametrically opposed to Sony
yes whereas Sony is using hardware
numbers to propel their system and the
old train of thought
Microsoft has zero problems with
forgoing a lost cause right they know
going forward ok this is a new battle
this is a new strategy this is a new way
to win and they're looking at the long
haul so the long haul is this you have
this high priced item which will be the
series at X yeah go on up against the
PlayStation 5 now whatever the
PlayStation 5 price point is I believe
that Microsoft will match them dollar
for dollar no matter what they love the
power narrative is ok because they're
going to make the money up in services
and the two weaker systems that they
will be having at the market where they
can make money off of those we all know
traditionally a lot of people a lot of
the masses doesn't have 4k televisions
and 4k televisions are at a point right
now where they're becoming more common
places in people homes so the
televisions are breaking down when they
go to the store they can get a you know
$200 $300 for k television and then they
will get a regular series s that 1440p
system and plus you got to realize like
how many people buy a console just to
play mad and just fight to Caleb
can i play too kid yeah yeah wrap it up
shoutout to John Moore glue it with the
dog super chat series as minecraft bond
will sell like hotcakes again how many
people just wanna play Minecraft right
so this is where they make the money and
also stay competitive
I believe that Microsoft's whole thought
pattern is not about really hardware is
about the ecosystem is about getting
people into their system if you're
playing on the PC if you're playing on
your phone wherever you're playing as
long as you're playing right so I
believe that they're flexible when it
comes to price wise like I like I see
the $2.99 I believe the $2.99 is going
to be the price of the Lockhart I
believe that's going to upset it from
the beginning I said if they really want
to do that pin to move that up into
attack oh yeah
you attacked you attack with the the
cheapest console you can possibly put
out there while still having specs that
can run next-gen games and you know a
council they can run at 1440p or 1080p
lock 60 frames per second or locks while
still having the bells and whistles of
retracing and things like that obviously
even trade offs but when you have you
still have the bells and whistles and
that's never steam that anything I mean
the main thing that's an advantage is
that unlike the Xbox 1s and the Xbox 1x
they you know saying like that CPU jump
is really gonna be substantial you know
I'm saying
actually even have to overclock they
join some Jaguars to get that Jane you
know say so to have those ends and all
that in there it's a good thing let me
jump in real quick cuz um I definitely
think you guys are onto something
the whole thing is I agree with you slow
up I think this is a stock clearing move
I think this is all about getting these
things out of there that's why we see in
their cyberpunk um console cuz how does
he he was you made a good point is jus
what we shouldn't technically be seeing
an Xbox 1x cyberpunk bundle now
like the game don't come out to
September right so funny I'm gonna say
now and the key is June cuz we figure
junior figure the new consoles will
start ramping up they gotta get these
old joints out of there that's my my
logic on that and I think yeah I think
they will Lockhart and um the Anaconda
will kind of replace what's existing and
to what Ranch point they probably may
still keep the shoddy around just
because again it's a low entry point
digital-only
lowest possible way to get into the
ecosystem and it's probably like king of
sands probably still doing numbers so
they probably keep that around and then
obviously you know they have the X cloud
and all other stuff for the non console
markets and stuff but yeah I agree I I
think the key to me is when I seen
cyberpunk console releases early of like
yeah y'all getting this out of me and
the most interesting thing to me is that
the fact that they did drop it to that
base $300 price point preparing the
market for that price point right
obviously they're not preparing the
market for that price point for the for
the series X right
so that Dad differential that $200
differential I agree with King a hundred
percent I think when Phil wasn't joking
when he said we're gonna be we're not
gonna be meek we're gonna be bold even
even if $500 the series X at $500 is a
slight loss to them I think you take
major loss yeah you take that upfront
my hope is that they're thinking at
Microsoft and Xbox is that in order to
regain mindshare loss upfront and like
King said you make it up with the
services so you're not losing you not
necessarily you'll be losing money on
the actual console and unfortunately if
you use money on one console you're
gonna just use gonna exponentially lose
more money but but slow making it up on
the software side consider they're gonna
bundle at least if not three I think I
think four I think it's three months um
definitely with it
but some see for every series s that
they sell for every series X that they
sell it on a sell at least four series
essence mm-hmm
you understand so if you're making if
you're taking a loss of a hundred
dollars fifty to a hundred I don't think
it's a hundred dollars
if you're taking a loss from 50 to $100
on the X right and you make it $70 on
each s sold value understand it balances
way out if you're selling a four to one
ratio and then you have to remember the
price of manufacturing these consoles is
constantly in flux whereas you get a
year two years into the lifestyle into
the lifetime of the console it's gonna
get cheaper to manufacturer where
whatever that deficit is in terms of
what you're losing on the console keeps
shrinking and shrinking and shrinking
until one day you maybe make money on it
and at that point it's when went all the
way around right and you're probably
ready for the Refresh at that point 218
in each app please hit that like button
you know I would definitely have some
fun today oh yes
what say he says he says to me cog I
think the old digital Xbox one system
has a chance of being $99 which I think
about that yeah yes yeah going for I
mean I gotta see I'm dying to know how
they reveal Lockhard go like Lockhart is
like that mystery secret weapon it's
like the weapon that everybody knows
exist we just haven't seen it we guys
might yeah get it well my question is do
you think they're going to show a price
for the Lockhart when they revealed that
B hello aggressive do you think yeah do
you think let's let's say the may event
is focuses completely on the console and
stuff you could little price there
before and get that out of the way think
I think they were everything I think
we've got a price on the law card if
it's 300 because of all that's showing
is like they're not gonna show the X is
one they're going to show the the S it's
gonna like for Sony to be like yo the
they're showing a $300 console and we a
showed a price yet what you know we
could hear more from Sony by then but I
doubt it so you know I do think that
hello grows I think I think they'll show
a price point if if you go in there and
put all the meat on Table Talk and you
say $300 for the s and that's what your
1440p system 1080p 60 frames law
with ray-tracing and Abel you can play
the big-boy stuff in a little boys box
and pause and you and you you have that
there
what type of panic do you put the other
words in listen I know I don't care what
anybody say $100 $100 when it came to
you know that their PlayStation for
cheap dudes went out and purchased that
I okay either way
listen listen listen dudes that was beat
down from that 360 it was like oh I'm
definitely going so would you refer you
as beat down this gym like oh yes you do
you what do you hear me every week
talking about field ominous Maximus I'm
following it to the promised land
opening up the you gotta really
understand one thing about me these
dudes is on my timeline oh hashtagging
missing every bit of presence no I did
work coming at me and I beat back every
last one of them even you won't shake my
hand one of the two now there is nobody
on my timeline talking anything right
now and that's all dude the field
ominous Maximus spin sir sir because I
put I hitch my wagon to that dude and he
has been leading us out of the darkness
so right now I'm telling you right now
if you come and he throw the meat on the
table pause if he do that with the 300
dollars on that s you might as well pack
up your stuff and all that hundreds
million soul is
/ God of War might not make it out the
box done that every goes back to King's
point earlier when he said that he kind
of wanted feel to pull back a little bit
and and gave himself the opportunity to
react to something that Sony does
instead of just putting out information
right and in if he puts out that price
point at 3:00 right doesn't talk about
the series X then that pushes they say
that push is so needed to talk did you
say okay we're gonna show them that the
are five hundred dollar console and then
it allows fuel to come right back with
the narrative were like wow John says
five - so would you yeah and we're
stronger right boom give the opportunity
that clap back that crime bag that King
is talking about that he hasn't seen
right they've been aggressive they've
been coming out with the message England
Sony hasn't had barely any messaging
King wants to see him clap back you know
what I want
did you do when y'all did that dead
disrespectful joint to me personally
well y'all see this is how we should
remember the little haha I swear I want
PlayStation father to be like at our
price point because mark Cerny
Magic Mike is $4.99 I won Microsoft to
come right back five minutes later yeah
me too yo shut the shade download the
five powers of a chat hit that like guys
this is for King speech I bend the be
cell says the book of Acts you aspire
this the oppressed today they sat there
and he took it listen I took every fight
for y'all I went every general any view
that job pointed I was like him King I
would write them and I wiped them off
the board they all off the board
they're not bothering y'all y'all are
running around free-range chicken
do something personal on behalf of the
Xbox community we thank you for you and
you know what any any young dudes I'm
gonna tell you right now if you'll
notice Phil no cuz he listened field
ominous Maximus pin let me let me tell
you something
any news talking about job was reppin
him day one no he wasn't
I was and i'ma tell you this when he
leads you all the way to and you having
fun with your little asses your little
X's understand I always told you they
send them into Puccini with a butter
knife and it he came out with a winner
winner chicken dinner
no pubsey reference you remember step up
definitely digs your orders of the I get
before I even get to the super said
Jonathan be leading us to the promised
land without the love I need to be
honest with you man how do you think we
need to go on anymore after them after
the king and the king the hero we don't
deserve but - really need jonatha be we
were lost sheep before King switch at
the book of X's out here Phil Dominic
Spencer who did that for you and all
that no that's bad gobble expense is
going on and then tighten 29 2793 with
the fine I love super chat thanks King
for the cleanup work they know for a
fact these dudes without hair beastmode
in these dudes on Twitter and I just had
to come and mop them up I had to mop him
up and get him about it he's gonna shake
this hand you're gonna take this bullet
[Laughter]
last topic with your body this would be
quick shadow shot above NJ no money $2
kick out here like battleship sunk
[Laughter]
yes saloon fire I'll bake this quick man
so look just real quick we got some -
sobs favorite genre the turn-based I
mean I'm not hating like I used to oh
boy oh boy
disgusting I hate it we used to play it
back in the day with you you know to do
behind the wheel okay this is nothing to
do with you solved but you just reminded
me of something
look I need to put some fraud put the
fraud alert up put the fraud alert up
this is to all the peoples I know how
almost such a deep I know G word well
that none of you cared about the X
column genre and two they popped that
Gary's name on and now everyone and they
moms like now you know what adding I'm
gonna try gears tactics you know I never
played these ex-con games but I'm not a
shy you know you know what brought me
into this yes I would hear this Mario
rabbits big out of all of them I think
that's one of the worst ones which came
in hot for you a turn-based strategy I'm
in now you know all that time we used to
sit and play XCOM in that room and
people was pissed all but we said babies
having fun we started a opieop I guess
she goes off god yah despised will we
play that I never do it was me it was
he's trying to protect someone trying to
pawn the store by himself
and I was ready to play you a full
defense your foes defense I had it for
ps1 we discussed we had but it was
definitely the most fun because you
didn't know what was around the corner
and if you ran around that corner cuz it
was blocked it was black and if you ran
around that corner you missed the wrong
spot young man was dead it wasn't even
like those old ones it wasn't even that
he was dead like you would they would
they would throw the fire of radon JD
game $2 - I see I see fill as we wade
through the water over good we got
massive possession we gotta catch up
that's a big Dallas they go to Dallas
who preached at King be
prime our flowers the Pichette addict
Your Honor something with that one bit
but this is but this is a good because
hashtag gaming diversity is great no
like like don't get me wrong like I'm
playing ex-con literally right now I
love this genre and you could ask our
Lord Cardinal Lord King
like what May and now it's gears taxes
I'm like I'm there I'm all that I said
let me get hold on we get the lady in a
brown ever cuts for the wind to show its
support for the iron laws of Sunday so
that's what's up
so like I want to bring it to y'all real
quick um in reference to we got to turn
based games coming right we got gears
tactics you don't say Microsoft of ray
into it the turn-based John we saw the
gameplay trailer a lot of stuff looking
at it kind of nice you don't say then we
got the old G coming back sobs favorite
XCOM chimera edition I believe one is
coming out to 24th I believe X comes
coming out first right right and then 24
to 28th I believe is oh here's tactics
okay so I just want to get obviously
impressions that Oh get it Kate laughs
we can also jump in I was gonna get I'm
really upset I'm really I said and then
the only way that field ominous maximus
splints I can make it up the mall that's
when the city's s releases or the series
X releases and they have a collapsible
keyboard and mouse that I'll add on the
couch um because let me tell you
something I was really looking forward
to these games being my console and and
the fact that they just being launched
in PC first I had what you're trying to
do I had no no he's trying to do he's
trying to get me to turn on this rig
right over here it's a to to play it and
he said is available you choose not to
go on your PC and play tell you I
understand like the PC gamer he's still
trying he's not worried about the PC
gamer getting game pass ultimate he
see game adjust getting game pass on PC
and soon have to to that and you have to
try to make the PC Gamer feel special
and give it and that they feel this for
them but they got a lot of things in the
PC game past and I've noticed that it's
not on that console game pass and I'm
like it looks a minute I want equality
impasse for the console but well for the
most part those are games that aren't
necessarily PC centric games they are on
console to get that but there are
certain scenarios where like
particularly like ages and part
completely understandable that game is a
PC game because they're building that
game around the PC world but is that if
if coalition's come out was like yo this
game is going to be on the Xbox then I'm
just like why isn't it on the Xbox day
one not really a menu the only gear the
last bastion of the PlayStation nation
Christopher and I didn't destroyed
everybody you Jeff and I definitely
respect the love the fact that you are
here laughs my butter off right now wait
is king fraud in four pcs of keys games
on the PC first I thought she was all
about that piece listen I'm all about
that right what I'm saying is if it
launches over there please let it launch
all the eggs you know they have a
strategy thing is I don't have to agree
with everything okay you're not gonna
hear me say oh everything that Microsoft
does is fantastic no game that I was
looking forward to I have guests on my
PC but I think that I was looking
forward to playing on my couch oh it
would be with my controller I was under
the foolish assumption it didn't the
thing it's not a thing for me and maybe
it's too complicated for a controller
but XCOM if X comes available and it's
able to do on was available but to be
fair XCOM to was put on PC and then in
the next box last button at the same
time it's just like the original one was
so what they do is is they prioritized
it they wanted it out by certain times
so
PC was the first one but it's just like
you're not a third party Microsoft like
it like you can't keep asking people
like your core audience not to get upset
when you're not giving exclusive content
for the console but you're giving it for
PC I understand the format and they're
playing the long game and this is what
I'm talking about like when you think
well they need a long game the thing
about it is they like I said they have
to convince you see game we think that
their games in a number you gotta try to
convince them to pay $10 a month or
whatever first your service on on on the
PC side if you really want game paths to
blow up and rule the world this is a
different world if you really want game
path to be everywhere and to be Vic
witness you know this is a move they
have to make you think so but what all
right I hear what you're going with the
long play but what about messaging right
from from the Xbox community has been
told that it is a good thing that their
games are playable on PC and for the
most part they have now you know
assimilated into this by said that this
is what it is and now kind of
PlayStation is going through it right
now right right they were gone their
titles and stuff for some of these
titles are going on right let's move on
getting in Lund I get it but what about
the message when you say yeah we got
this new game but we go give it to PC
first I get your reasoning sob I really
get I really do but the optics from the
Xbox console guys like hey why don't we
get this also why we gotta wait kind of
in it I absolutely wanna person get it
you're right because they have said
listen our day and date right Dane date
everywhere right and this is not that
their date and a in-game pass they did
which version
thank you brother 100% get it but to me
when you look at what is the biggest
gaming community right
besides the phone right right after the
phone is PC game right not play not Xbox
yeah how do you bring them in and get
them to move away from how they usually
write it
yeah their game right you just you gotta
do it you gotta do and even if it fails
you just selfishly I did was this game
so bad or I'm working I what this game
is all in it looks so fight a virtue
[Music]
let me get SWAT in this because this is
this is this is community you know then
you are the PC master-race you are the
og from back in ILP pioneering and final
ease I have caught up to you and I have
assimilated to your thinking and we used
to fight now we're on the same fan so
where you at with this type of stuff
SWAT as far as you don't all gears
tactics and then obviously X Carmen PC
these are PC exclusive zippers I mean I
think it's I think it's cool I like it
I'm not really one to complain about
getting games you're good yeah with that
out of the way King is that pcs
collecting dust you were selling one of
those 1080 T eyes no no I'm gonna keep
my do 1080p eyes right there and what
I'm gonna do is do you all have to bend
it into I my enemy sir mmm-hmm going to
I'm going to need download it and play
it if I told you wait a second
I don't care how much I rant them rage I
have the opportunity to go down and this
is this is where I flipped the script on
Christopher Christopher see it's a
difference between sitting there and
crying in my puddle of piss please but a
snot bubble in my nose
crying talking borrowed it put it on PC
you know got a PC no I got a PC
phenomena and me you can play it over
there if you can't play it over there
because you're part of our ecosystem
Thank You King have a nice day so I'm
gonna go downstairs and I'm going to
play my gears tactics day and date a
game ass
no money up brother that is true he
definitely did definitely definitely dig
a passageway - oh my god continue slide
does that does it you have a piece yes
as a PC gamer primarily right do you
feel that's a good like what - what's
obviously do you feel that's a good move
for you to entice you to feel like you
know what I do want to play this well I
do want to get you already said you got
game passed already on PC yeah you love
that deal so how do you feel about that
from dumb catering to your to your life
personally I feel like it's hard to kind
of relate because I jumped on the game
pass right away because I mean it was
already it seems kind of like logical to
me because I was already enjoying a lot
of like to play anywhere stuff so I was
already behind games yeah or that
yeah state of decay and res equals seven
yes that was a lot of fun but um I mean
there are options out there if you if
you have a PC that I mean you can run
Nvidia shield and yes project that to a
different spot in your house but the
hardline connection so you get you know
low latency gaming in that if even with
Xbox if you have PC and Xbox you can
actually you'd actually stream the Xbox
the PC to the Xbox use them like
miracast and things like that oh I've
been using it but I've really enjoyed
I've been using it a lot like glad you
said a it works really well
definitely yeah you know gamepad support
it's confirmed
wait it's good for what no mouse and
keyboard for what what's that again what
there's no gamepad support for tactics
okay there is it confirmed I can't see
why they wouldn't it's got to be in game
pass I mean you can map you can map
buttons to a controller so it'll like
just using oh yeah the apps okay sorry
like accessories apps you could you
could probably just map the buttons
where you need them solve your question
is one PC can use controller no he's
talking about on um on that streaming
thing that he's talking about right now
you talk about
that's box to your PC can you use a
private one is natural yeah if you have
if you have Bluetooth yeah if you have
Bluetooth enabled on your PC or if you
have it enable on your laptop or
whatever you're using rollers USB right
into it you'll see my face right here
did you just see the king probably got a
bypassed by the firewall Xbox Lily for
buying it right plug it right in
recognize windows drivers immediately
with those terribili recognizes as an
Xbox controller full functionality
instant seconds but that controller also
works over Bluetooth - yes yes and if
you have a Bluetooth enabled PC then you
know it's just like playing like
standard Xbox yep the wireless
controller and if you don't if you don't
however if PlayStation if you're using a
ps4 exactly if you're even have a
wireless adapter if you don't want to be
tethered they even have one for that oh
god no by using the ps4 controller oh my
god I know unless you play some
PlayStation like God of War some and
even then I would love to play God of
War with Xbox controller oh but yeah
let's get out of here man because
obviously we are the RTS you know
actually terminates the TBS he's RTS I'm
Morty field so what do you think man we
got Chimera and we got gears tactics to
turn base jump off jumping off is it the
resurgence is it on now is it on a
poppet I think that's it XCOM has made
this genre a lot more successful it's
able to succeed a lot easier I still
think it's got a long way to go it's
it's kind of like it reminds me a lot of
like the dark souls franchise like that
one game opens the door but other games
opens the the dam mm-hmm
so you know we'll have to see you know
cuz gears tactics the good thing about
it that has over X column is it already
has an in-house
name yes and so it's like you got people
like Eric I never played ex-con
interested Kofi is playing it right now
like you know it gets it get it
it gives a lot more opportunities for
more people to like this genre and then
after they beat that they're like you
know what I like this game let me go try
you know let me go try XCOM you know as
much as I didn't like Mario rabbits same
thing mm-hmm
Mario universe and it gave a lot more
people be incentive to try in branch out
Philly a girl agrees with you because um
we do we would consider XCOM oh gee you
know I'm saying as far as opening the
door for a lot of these turn-based joins
to be cool and now people are
capitalizing it and their whole universe
this gate King and in the nd franchise
the indie scenario is doing these games
like crazy
yes yes I saw them playing phantom
doctrine shout out to Eric cuts for the
wind she played a con to for a bit
mostly Fire Emblem and Mary o rabbits
beat those he's excited for gasps static
maybe I should this know had before
passed if we know XCOM comes out first a
couple days first ain't no perfect well
let's say they came out the same day
play first probably excellent just
because it's it's shorter so I think I
can I can knock that out quicker
but if I were playing if if they came
out if they were like if it was XCOM
three yes and gears tactics gears don't
even know who you did go sell more
probably I don't know I think game pass
it's in game pass so it's it sells are
gonna be you know a little bit hit
because of gaming past which isn't a bad
thing that's literally what they want
gears tap X comms only $20 to so you
know that means a lot when your games
only $20 and it's all made with seventh
yeah so you know it's gonna be
interesting to see exactly what it says
that's for sure I already pre-ordered
yes or solver you picking up any of
these two I'm picking up both of them
told you I'm end I told you this that's
easy
yeah of course
listen like I said and you guys have not
listened to me I told you to play into
the breach a long time ago I told you
guys to say that game looks like dog s
it is the most fantastic like strategy
sort of roguelike small little tidbits
like you can just keep playing that game
over and over and over again every time
every single little stage is a puzzle
unto itself its asset you need to play
into the breach I played it so besides
so besides into the breach obviously I
said Mario rabbits brought me in me like
what I see with these two games is that
honestly when you know that you say they
are they making a comeback right they
are cuz I think they're elevating the
genre in a way both of them you know in
ways that we haven't seen for a while
like obviously with chimera squad you
have no permanent permanent then you
have a focused squad like it's not that
you're creating a path I don't I don't
think you could compare XCOM to like
that game to the general XCOM I think
the reason this game is existing is
because they're about to announce XCOM
three like this they want to set the
world up to let people really to feel
what the world is like in Xcode like
these characters in Khmer are going to
be in it that's why the story is five
because unless they all die at the end
of the game which if they want you to
have more of an emotional attachment to
the story then maybe that's the reason
but to me yes it's like that right it's
either they all die and the whole story
leads right into XCOM three or it's just
this distance or third the enemies of
XCOM three it could be it could be so to
me the things they're doing with that is
something you haven't really seen in
ours yes right and then when you a Gears
here is it saying okay how do we keep
the action orientation of years and put
it into an RTS what do you do you first
of all you have free range of movement
right you don't really have grid
movement now right you have three moves
that you could make at any give
as opposed to - which expects commas
always been right then how they change
over watch yes the change to over R
square basically it's just you funneling
out like this this this this
line-of-sight cone vision and then as
the cone vision expands more the further
away your enemies the less likely you
are to hit them right so it's a matter
of it's a matter it lends strategy to
that right and then why you keep the the
whatchamacallit the assassinations and
stuff like that that is classic two
gears right you chain two on people and
stuff like that to me
you're bringing the RTS into in into the
present day where you're you're keeping
action elements people that may not be
and certainly enjoy the plotting nature
of back and forth back and forth your
turn my turn my turn right make it more
action-oriented while still making it
deep I think moving the genre forward I
would not be surprised both of these
games mmm bring new people to the John
King are we excited his tactics squad
I was excited when I first saw both of
them announced um when I first saw today
I woke up and the first thing I see when
I look up there's like two messages from
from one from call 8 Cognito showed me
the announcement trailer and then
literally right after it show it was the
announcing the trains like they're about
to announce the trailer the next word
was the trailer I felt like I woke up
for Christmas well I don't we lit that's
our favorite game could be yeah but I
think secretly Brian went in and helped
collab on Gears tactics because one and
all the stuff that he said that he hated
and XCOM first is visually pleasing yes
it has it keeps the action there so and
it also keeps the core of Gears I think
this does what Gears did to cover base
shooting I agree Oh buddy as somebody
who got ripped into a couple of weeks
back for saying that gears needed to
change that God
you mean attic attic and the whole a
grown woman gave in this is yoga I will
say this they can keep doing whatever
they want with regular gears and if they
give me side stuff like this maybe maybe
this it's got me wanting them to buy
Splash Damage just to make stuff like
this like and no don't make just gears
like the toilet is laughs it's like you
know like do something with Halo in this
kind of game see listen hey a little bit
halo but that's a different kind ER
stand that that's a different thing but
that was also outside of the box yes let
halo wars continue to be a hi-low Awards
entity and not do a real-time strategy
thing with that even though they kind of
did it with that uh halo assault thing
um it was like a source Morton Salt yeah
but I liked it though I liked it though
be honest with you I like a tree arcs
and all that stuff I love that thing um
but then this gears let let this gears
be what is going to grow into mm-hmm
because we complain that Microsoft is
continuing the same creature but see
this this this hamburger right here got
lettuce tomatoes Bacon's and onions on
it
this is a burger but it's a little bit
different
and I think they need the dryness no
Baconator stuff on your like you guys
bake it on it I think this I think this
is going to do what the first gears did
for the Xbox
I think this gears tactics is going to
do that in the PC from the first month
will tell you I know for a fact that
when it launches on the console it's
going to have the same reverberations as
a real Gears online mainline game when
it drops
I am super pumped man like this was
about two hours exciting for this topic
obviously you know term base for me
it has literally become Loki my number
one genre lately obviously the destiny
stuff always obedia but the games that
when I started and addict knows when you
get a new XCOM and you get a new
whatever I can't stop playing like is
something about setting up putting your
people you don't in the map controller I
see the thing solver saying is so far
about tactics is that it's the gears
universe graphically it looks phenomenal
we're getting a good a tremendous story
with cakes
you're a prequel cakes dad you don't
saying it looks amazing the cinematic
storytelling which I like that they
doing kind of like what halo wars there
cuz I was jealous like man that looks
amazing
now I'm not an RTS guy I'm more of a
turn-based guy right so this is for me
then I like that it's a very aggressive
day you know saying like it's like if
you get an execution you kill you go
again you go again
so it's almost like these hordes of
enemies coming on to you and you have to
deal with that that aspect of the XCOM
to has something like that what was it
called the Horde or something I think a
horde move yeah it's basically a more
when you're overwhelmed by almost like
zombies and non-stop of the laws so lost
right so that's the vibes getting me
then let's be real ex-con I mean gears
fit so well in that universe the whole
thing about gays is boom slamming into
the cover that's X Conan like that
that's what I really like what they you
know they didn't just take the the genre
and just copy it like I hate when people
take X calm and they don't try to
improve the ability to take word for
word they definitely got the split on
some super pump for that and of course
the old G's coming with a new look you
got aliens this is my excellent we got
aliens humans working together tactical
team then what I like that's all gonna
like they've got breach phrases are
phases think riot to stealth in and
depending on how you do the situation go
but they also change the formula wicks
like you pick order order or Ave go you
go they go you go something like that
team synergy moves and I green up you
guys get it I think it's safe to say
that all of these features will be in
the new one so I also think I love the
concept of this piece between the
Haman's and Ally
this city of them living together and
they need this camera squat to keep the
peace because if there's anarchy this
could go off reverberate against the
world a piece could be over so they're
setting up the law which is gonna be
fire which I like I'm excited man I
think that we mentioned that and the
breach mode I forgot to mention it has
me really excited because you know what
it reminds me of what do you remember
when we used to play Rainbow six I don't
play C's or seems basically this did
this this concept how we set each other
up everybody breached the house from a
different place different just doing
that sort of stuff is so much fun of
fact I love that game I think that game
that was a good game I guess the reason
I'm more excited for x-phone their own
gears it's because it's because first
they so close to each other like that
was intentional like yes weird yeah well
maybe you know you have the classic
dudes that's looking for the XCOM name
and while they're doing it you know then
you have the gears dudes they just don't
want to miss out on their own on a
strategy may you want my honest opinion
I think talk cuz I've played a lot of
these games I've played a lot of the
I've reviewed a lot of these types of
games for I ope I think until I saw a
Gears tactics Gears tactics is the only
game I've ever seen that could give XCOM
a run for its money that's all John yeah
and I think that's the reason that
they're doing this is because they
respect Gears tactics and they
understand that you know because they've
launched all kinds of stuff and they've
never reacted they're like you know what
it is what it is but the old gears taxes
are like they actually know what they do
say like I gotta give it I gotta throw
the gold up doing a flip phone man
sticking nlg Rainbow six for the
Dreamcast FTW oh my love that's goats
look right there you're you're the
subject ah
no double yeah that's all I got really I
be I'm just super excited I guess off
you should have a billy goat yeah
I do really think that both of these
games coming out so close to each other
if you think about it it is one of those
situations I think that you know rising
tide raises all boats mmm I think both
of them coming out and close proximity
if you really think about it I think
they just they help each other and they
help the John Rose yes that's why I'm
excited again it's my favorite genre you
know he doesn't really get a lot of love
in the console space in the PC space
it's moving but in the console so I'm
just one I would love these both to do
well and then you know console guys we
get our hands on it as well and I'm not
working though anyway okay bro you read
a wedding I'm in me like I ain't in the
story but that's how it's supposed to be
you're supposed to go over the games or
what it games are so we ain't crying and
it's over there we just saying we go we
gonna be over here we're betting that
it's it's stupid but we ain't waitin
either that's why the Final Fantasy
thing you know I hate that it's not on
Xbox but I want waiting a year to play
the games I'm gonna tell you this it's
not this is it's they allow us to do it
they have it there they put it there
that's what they want you to gain they
want you to engage the I guess they need
those numbers up over there you know as
far as game pass goes and they want
those you know the to see the litmus
test it might be a litmus test this
might be what this is rocking new ILP
poll this week with recent evidence
suggesting that limited PlayStation 5
console availability at launch how do
you think this affects PS 5 when it
actually launches in comparison to the
series X the choices are a big effect
especially if PS 5 has lower
availability at launch and Xbox Series X
is the same price choice B no effect
Sony gamers will wait on PlayStation 5
availability to remain it's not for
their pre-orders see depends on
compelling software lineup for the Xbox
series X and D I don't care for Atticus
door switch
is company hot buddy I had made this a
change well we had to fight like
literally for the kind of crazy you'll
see with all the low as we go ahead add
Twitter up in all that mess with
everybody in the chat Lord SWAT the
returning og coming through the round
good to see you man wicked if I people
find you what you got going on sir
good to see you guys thanks for having
me absolutely you can find me on Twitter
at Lord SWAT alt p you can also find me
on youtube at stam Ian Chen yes our
gaming youtube no doubt salute to you
and lady pan if i show me the utmost
hops hospitality animal crossing took me
into your home showed me play music it
was great come looking for gifts - yes
give a gift so i took that flight out
there you know say it's a yacht island
yours this a salute oh they shout the
lady panning the realm always welcome
again one of the best marriages ever
gaming marriages ever salute your zi was
out there shouted it sounds in texas you
really absolutely really know family
already know and of course lord addicts
having very feisty times today
able to recover very nicely like we do
that still my brother we fight when this
is just a passionate that's how we are
it's always love lord addict wicked upon
people finds what you got going on sir
you can find me a target buying that new
210 dose which when it drops you can
find me on twitter at Lord edit I'll be
you'll find me on how many times someone
will say that in you and you still laugh
on that after enough of them you'd be
like I already know what's how know what
it is because you don't say that Twitter
yes with the time it's so hot I'm you
can find me there you find me on youtube
the gaming addicts and you can find me
next week here
no Lord sovereign the new turn-based
strategy king his favorite job where he
is backed out at the graphics are good
IOP + bx sovereign on PSN and xbox live
and shots are in the chat today we like
to you bought a time always live as
always later
yeah you guys are coming in to watch the
support man I appreciate that much love
Lord King starting tremendous troubles
evil genius scientists completely
manipulates me an addict to fight and
even I was gonna be on that side so that
I didn't even know the topic like a
moment I'm like no and I'm like above it
was amazing it was just how I planned it
I said add water
[Laughter]
King David OTW you can count on being me
too but yeah I music but if you follow
my lord King David that ain't me so um
don't follow him I don't know what that
guy's but um new Kos is coming up it's
going to be a statue that like I said
before I was chasing the statue down and
give a shout out to the guy that helped
me acquire the statue in this um out oh
yeah yeah definitely not yet no I need
to know it's coming
yeah and listen also I noticed something
a little weird um if you don't go inside
your settings on YouTube and you don't
click 4k I shoot all my video
in 4k fax and if you don't go shoot
click 4k a menu seeing money cuz I was
like I was going on with this video I
said you know I shooting 4k I said is it
the codec with Eugene but I went inside
my settings and YouTube there's a little
bar down at the bottom little three dots
you go outside and there's a setting you
go to the visuals and you can hit it I
hit 4k and boom pristine Christine look
beautiful the sound quality is even
better
mmm I'm so go check out those special
videos um also if you're a statues that
y'all didn't see if you're trying to
figure out if I have them if I put them
up hit us up hit us up at loads gave me
that net or hit us up on Twitter on our
own on lorgnette channel ass also and
you know we'll get right back at you
also do me a favor let's get it if y'all
think that the last word we'll all
kognito and Evon test is just you know
for destiny let me tell you something
y'all missing some of the greatest
fights ever see and I go there on the
greatest bullying that's oh wow but you
know what he bounces is on his bully
game back because I sit there and wait
for the kognito to poke and prod this
man put him to fight back and his fight
back is like a while pitbull
hold you down very very limited shot the
deal mentors yoeri the last words fight
you already know solo and speaking of
which thank you for the setup man again
we appreciate the support you know
coming up on 100 episodes for life mmm
100 so we're gonna do something big I'll
give you an exclusive down because your
ILP a yah family you know saying so
spread the word tell people we're gonna
have the law master there my name is
bikes for 100 man so it should be a nice
special one all shout the era cut for
the widow to crest up for Eric on for
the width
she just bought the ILP sir so much
appreciate it really
really appreciate the support but yeah
definitely support that will do that
Friday should be at the same time you
already knows to check us out and of
course please support my brother King
he's out here with this king of statues
doing improper please support again stop
just trying to watch the promo go we've
been cutting it yeah cut it down voting
noise again but not net the goal go to
the ILP YouTube channel please you know
I'm saying so definitely supported me
puts a ton of work he gives you
background synapses or the character
comic book references educating you Wow
showing you a million-dollar statue fan
support the me he's out I don't even go
there for the statue now I go there for
what's this character even you wouldn't
know I don't even know that about
certain like I didn't know that about
this character I didn't know like you're
gonna get a lesson the synapses is there
so please do that
yeah but I had to start the smaller cast
Final Fantasy 7 being an addict me an
addict will be doing more of these we've
been talking about how to seeing people
seem to like when we do some spoiler
Castle bow and that what's up I owe me
an addict bout to do that gain and me
and sovereignty so mean is gonna find
our way out there Jill because sovereign
left me in the jail he's no kid ok he's
like but you know it doesn't let go that
so yeah get please support that we'll be
doing that which I do more live reaction
I just stuff look everybody enjoy your
Sunday that's all I got if I got
anything else we are out of here hit
shot with this little fly outro and all
that good stuff everybody enjoy your
Sunday please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]